I'm very much focused
on getting things done.
I think that I took
every opportunity
to execute on something
as if it was the biggest thing
for the company.
Keren Fanan,
thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm great, thank you.
Fantastic.
Are you calling
from Israel right now?
Yes.
Yes, I'm in Israel today.
Wonderful.
I'm in Israel as well.
And it's great
to have you on this show
because I am very excited
to talk to you about
your position at Gett.
And not just your position
as Chief Commercial Officer at Gett,
one of the Israel's
proudest companies.
A unicorn within Israel that probably
every Israeli uses
to travel a daily basis,
at least on a weekly basis.
But I believe that it's branched
to be much greater than just
Israel at this point.
You'll tell us more about that.
But really, your journey within Gett,
and your journey as an entrepreneur,
as you mentioned previously,
I think will be fascinating.
But we have to start all the way
from the beginning from Cotopaxi.
What prompted you
to climb the largest volcano?
So, yeah.
That's a good question.
I mean, I was always a big fan of
doing of extreme, right?
So, bungee jumping
and jumping from a plane.
And I you know,
when I traveled in Israel,
it's quite common that
when you finish the army,
you usually go and travel
for a few good months.
So, I did my trip
at South America
and when I got to Ecuador,
I was told that there is
the highest active volcano
that if you want,
you can climb.
And it's as simple as that.
You don't need to prepare.
You don't need to do anything.
You just need to register.
Obviously, it was extremely difficult.
It's like 19,000 feet, right?
Like more than 5,000 meters tall.
Right. Yeah.
Like you don't climb everything
you can do part of the road by a car.
And then in order to climb to the cliff,
you have to wake up
at something like 12AM
because it's freezing there.
So you really need
to kind of wake up
when it's nighttime
and then you have special equipment
and you start to climb.
And by the sunrise you get to the top,
you get to see the sunrise,
and then you have
to go all the way down.
So, it was really kind of
once in a lifetime experience.
I'm sure. I'm sure.
And I have to say that
I can relate pretty close
to what you're saying.
I didn't climb Cotopaxi.
I climbed Kilimanjaro about
a year and a half ago with my family.
And we have to wake up at midnight
and climb during the night
so that we have better footing
on the frozen hills.
And it's probably one of
the most difficult things
I've ever done.
But that reward of getting up there,
we actually miss
the sunrise by a few minutes.
So, we have to do it again.
Sounds like it.
It's remarkable.
Keren, what is the responsibility
of a chief commercial officer
at a company like Gett?
So, obviously, like commercial
or revenue responsibility,
maybe a little bit different
between companies.
So, at Gett,
the responsibility includes
to drive the revenue
from our core business units.
One of our main business units
at Gett is the B2B activity,
which we have recently developed into
a more of a global SaaS product.
So, as chief commercial,
I'm actually managing all of
the sales organization as well as
the account management,
but also the marketing activity.
And I'm also, you know,
overlooking the acquisition
and retention in our consumer business.
So, basically everything
that generates revenue
to the company sits within
the commercial unit.
It's a little bit important
from what I'm gathering.
Yeah. A little bit.
Money is important.
In most cases.
But Keren, most of us know Gett
as a B2C product.
I'm ordering it through in my app,
and I go down there.
What is a B2B initiative
of a ridesharing company like Gett?
Yeah.
That's a great question, because Gett
is indeed known
for being a consumer company because
that's how it was kind of born.
But not many people know that right after
the launch of the consumer service,
Gett also launched a B2B service
for corporations and basically developed
a technology that helps companies
to manage their taxi rides
for their employees.
So, for example,
if you work for a company
that, you know,
and you need to travel quite a lot
for work purposes.
So, if in the past you had
to go take a taxi, keep the receipt
and then reimburse it,
then and expense it,
then today by using the Gett platform,
you don't really need
to do it because everything is managed
by the Gett system
and all you have to do
is just to kind of switch
to the business profile,
book a taxi, and that's it.
It's as simple as that.
And what we've lately also been doing
is to take the same platform globally
by integrating into
the local providers.
So, we started by announcing
a partnership with Lyft
in the US because Gett
do not operate in the US,
but also with Ola in London
and Carey International,
which is a large chauffeur service
and so on and so forth.
We keep on integrating
into many, many providers.
So, slowly we are kind
of creating a global ecosystem of all
of the existing providers,
the consumer providers
that we all know,
and we make it more accessible
for business purposes.
It sounds complicated,
exciting and pretty innovative to
for a company that where there was
a consumer centric up until now.
But you're adapting
to the emerging needs, obviously,
of all of these different corporations.
But Keren, you have an even more unique
to what you're doing
is the journey of how you got there.
So, starting at entry level.
So before that,
you spent few years at AT&T.
Technical Project Manager now
and then moved into
R&D Product Management.
How does that work
entering a company like Gett
as an entry level and making your way
to C-level with internally?
Tell me a little bit about
the process and the challenges
that go with that.
I'd love to.
So first of all,
I think I would divide it
to two kind of major transitions. Right?
The first one was the fact
that I moved from R&D
and tech organizations into operations.
Because when I joined Gett,
I joined as
a marketing operations manager,
which pretty much means
that you need to execute all of
the global marketing projects.
Before that, my experience
was solely based on R&D and technology
and releasing new versions
to become live
and deploy new versions.
So, that change was quite massive because
it's completely different language,
different phase,
and that was great.
I think Gett has given me
the opportunity to move
from tech to operations
without any experience in marketing.
Because they believe, in general,
it's a company that believes
that if you have the skill set
and the motivation,
you do not necessarily need to have
the super specific relevant experience,
which I really believe in that.
Because I think that
when people brings
their different experiences
from different roles
and different departments,
they actually create something
very much unique
and diverse rather than just kind
of doing the same over and over again.
So, I joined Gett
as marketing operations manager,
which is, as mentioned,
an entry level position.
And since then
I started off like crazy journey
or rollercoaster,
if you want to call it.
I think that there were several things
that helped me in that journey.
First of all, I'm very much focused
on getting things done.
I think that I took every opportunity
to execute on something,
as if it was the biggest thing
for the company.
Looking back,
I know that many of the things
that I've done at the beginning
were not that important.
But if we were talking
five and a half years ago,
you would hear me talking about it
as if that is going to change
the face of the company.
I love it. I love that.
And I think that it's
a part of the thing,
because when you
kind of approach something
as if it's the most important thing
and you execute it in the best
possible way, which means that
if someone's asked you to do this,
you will do something here. Right?
Like way beyond,
think out of the box
and most importantly, execute.
Right?
That is a critical thing.
And I was lucky enough also to, again,
to work in a company
that embraced innovation
and embraced execution.
So, when my manager saw
that I'm capable of executing that,
he gave me more challenges.
So, the next challenge that I got was
to launch a brand new idea that Gett had.
It was right at the time
that Gett changed its name
from Get Taxi to Gett.
And they had this crazy idea
that Gett can get you anything.
So, you can get pizza on demand,
flowers on demand,
courier on demand
to do deliveries for you.
And my manager asked me
if you want to launch it,
it's sounds big,
it was just me doing everything,
seeing what we can do.
And that's how I started,
you know, that was the first step
in launching the first startup
within startup.
We started by launching
verticals at Gett,
different products
that you can get on demand.
And I remember
we had to do everything. Right?
Like engage with couriers.
We wanted to register them.
So we went and downloaded
like a freemium form online
and ask the couriers
to use the free form to register.
And then we brought them in
to do some kind of training session,
how to use the app.
So, you actually have to do everything
exactly like building a startup in your device.
Exactly like building a startup.
Right.
It's just did you do it within
an already operating company.
Obviously, you can leverage some
of the tools that exist,
but in most cases you really
have to do everything as if it's
the first time for the company.
So, I have been doing that
for several months after several months.
I think I had to learn
one of the greatest lessons,
which was to decide
what we do not do.
We started to do all
of this kind of crazy pizza sushi stuff
in 10 minutes,
but we had to acknowledge that
not all of these kind of channels
or services actually work.
And the only thing that actually
was well adopted
by the market in Israel,
but also in other markets
was the courier service.
So back then, so we decided
to kind of shut down all
of the products on demand.
Because getting flowers
in 10 minutes is cool.
But, you know, many people will pay
a little bit more to get
the specific bouquet
that they want, even if
they need to wait three hours.
Right?
That's an interesting
behavior observation.
And first of all, before you continue,
I have to say thank you,
because I am probably one
of the biggest users of Gett delivery
in my day to day life.
It completely changed
the way I think about logistics.
And I think that especially
for people that are busy
and they have stuff to do.
One of the things
that have been fascinating for me
over this past decade or so
is the amount of tools that are
at our disposal
to make our days more efficient.
And all of a sudden, you know,
10 years ago, if you were to ask somebody
if they have an alternative to go
to the store or drive 20 minutes
to the flower store
to pick up something
and bring it back,
there was no dilemma.
You have to do it.
Now, with the introduction of Gett delivery
and other services,
the whole consumer mindset has shifted.
And I really think that Get Delivery
had a pivotal role
in educating the market on that.
Educating consumer behavior.
You educated me
into thinking more critically about
what can I use technology for
in my day to day life
and what not.
So, thank you Keren.
And I'm already so happy
that we got to meet.
So, I just want to say thank you.
I'm happy to hear.
There's nothing
that makes me happier
than hearing people saying how
they like the service.
Obviously, I use it a lot as well.
But yes, I agree.
I think that Gett delivery kind of
you know, brings that
the importance of our time, right?
If we can save time
and use technology
to do stuff for us, that's amazing.
And I think it's something
that in the past
it did not exist at all.
A lot of the time,
most stores, most small businesses
don't have delivery service.
So, you're actually opening up
the a whole market.
Because if I now need
to get some plumbing equipment
from a few streets away,
then the only way before was
to go physically.
But please continue
with your journey.
Right?
Yes.
So, back to Gett delivery.
So back then, we had to decide,
like, I had to decide
to shut down some of the activities.
It's never a fun decision to decide that.
But I think that it was another kind
of step in the journey
to prove again to the company
that I'm capable
in the same way that I'm capable
of taking new stuff and trying them,
it's also okay to come and say,
look, this thing doesn't work,
this thing works better.
Let's double down on what works.
So, yeah, so we invest in more
in Gett delivery.
We expanded the service.
At this time, I was also promoted
to lead Gett delivery globally,
also in the UK and in Russia.
So, for the first time in my life,
I had to manage teams abroad
and hire people in different countries,
different cultures, different languages,
which was another critical step.
What was the hardest part
about shutting down some products?
So, taking that ownership
and what I'm hearing
in between the lines here
is that this was also kind
of a pivotal role in your career
as your not just this entrepreneur
that is excited and growing things
and saying, let's just run.
But you're also taking that accountability,
that leadership ownership over things
that aren't necessarily working
and saying to the company,
listen, this is my initiative.
Some worked, some didn't,
but I'm taking accountability
and I want us to succeed.
So, we have to be honest
and be intentional
with what we're doing.
Right.
Look, so first of all, again,
I was fortunate to have a manager
who is also a mentor and a coach.
It's Dave Wiser, the co-founder of Gett.
He was my direct manager
for the past five and a half years.
So obviously,
a lot of the things with things
that he can and challenge me to think,
on whether I could be more successful,
focusing on what works
and in general, in Gett,
it's something that we do quite a lot,
is to look at the data,
look at the numbers
and enforce ourselves
to kind of really think
what business decisions
we need to take based on this data.
Now, I'm not saying that everything
has to be solely based on data.
You always have to bring also
your own point of view.
And obviously,
I'm also a firm believer
that even intuition
has something to do with it.
But when you have clear facts
and you look at the numbers, you know,
it makes it easier.
By the way, shutting down the ventures
wasn't the most difficult thing.
Like, later on in my career,
we launched more ventures
and we had to close them as well.
And I'm talking about units
that got to be something like
30 people working on it.
So, yeah.
So, it happens, right?
If you allow yourself
to be innovative,
to try new things,
you just have to take into consideration
that some things works
amazingly well
but some just don't.
And if it doesn't work,
then you better shut it down
and move on.
Otherwise, it were just going to drag you,
pretty much drag you down.
100%.
Now, obviously,
you are an incredible entrepreneur
and you made an intentional decision
to be an entrepreneur
within an organization like Gett.
So, you founded these startups
within the larger organization of Gett.
And obviously it must have crossed
your mind saying, look, you know,
if I'm starting new startups here,
maybe like, you know,
I could just start
a startup on my own
and be an entrepreneur there.
What was your thinking
and why did you decide to do
it within a larger company?
So, that's a great question because,
you know, it took me a very long time
to be able to say it very openly, because
I do consider myself as an entrepreneur
to come and say, you know,
I believe that I bring a better version
of myself by being an entrepreneur.
Because I need
the environment that allows me
to be innovative rather
than starting something from scratch.
Now, I'm not saying
that in five years from today,
I may find myself, you know,
starting my own startup from scratch.
But, you know, the understanding that
you can be an entrepreneur inside
a company was something that for me
was a great revolution.
And I would love to share it because
I think that there are many people
that from one hand,
they feel this urge inside of them
of doing new things
and thinking outside
of the box and just to come
and be another person in a big
or small company,
but to do something unique.
But on the other hand,
they don't feel ready
or they don't feel that
what they want is
to start something from scratch.
And they don't feel also
that they want to join a company
of three people because
they need something more stable.
And the fact that
you can actually be
what I call entrepreneur.
And by the way, in my mind,
the definition of entrepreneur is
working for a company, building stuff
and acting as if you are the owner.
So you don't see yourself
as another employee.
You see yourself as the owner.
You see yourself in the same way as
the founder sees himself or herself.
And that's how you can operate.
You think in the same way
that the founder will think
it's just that you work for a company.
And the thing is
that for the founder,
this type of people,
the entrepreneurs,
they're the best kind of employees.
Right?
Because any founder would want
his team to be, you know, of people
that sees the company
as if it was their own.
I love it.
And to me, it was a great kind of,
just a great understanding that
I can feel comfortable
bringing my entrepreneurship urge,
you would call it,
just to be inside a company
rather than just building something
of my own.
I think that's inspiring
and that's a message
that a lot of people,
I think, need to hear right now.
There is, I think,
an understanding
or this motivation by a lot
of people that say,
Okay, if you want to be innovative
and create something
and be an entrepreneur,
you need to leave the comfortable company
that you love, perhaps,
and the people
that you work with that you love.
And you have to go on this lonely route
of being an entrepreneur.
And that's not necessarily the case.
I was just talking with
the chief revenue officer of HIPPO
where I work.
And we were talking late last night about
the different initiatives.
And he just got so excited
by all these different startups
that we're about to start
within the company.
And he said, you know,
"If you want to be an entrepreneur,
you don't have to go
and be on this lone soldier out there."
I think it can also do it
within the community
of a very supportive company
with the resources of the company
and still have a huge impact
and be an entrepreneur,
which is just phenomenal.
Keren, I want to really thank you.
I really want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
I know how busy you are
and I really appreciate that.
And before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay.
Yeah, so that was a tough one.
The hardest one.
Yes, I think that I would go with,
find your passion.
Because one of the things
that I've learned during my career,
comparing also the different roles
that I got to do during the years,
is that when you're passionate
about what you're doing,
it's like you're a different person.
Nothing is difficult enough.
Nothing is hard enough.
Everything is possible.
When you are not passionate,
everything becomes, not everything,
but things become a hassle.
Things become more difficult.
Everything becomes confusing.
And it's possible
to find your passion.
It took me
I think five or six years before
I really got this feeling
of saying, wow,
I'm so passionate about what I'm doing.
I cannot get enough of it.
So that's my choice.
I love it.
Keren, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
Continue doing amazing things
for Gett, for Israel,
for me as a consumer
and for businesses as consumers.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. You too.
Thank you very much.